The graph of the line
2y plus 3x equals
7 is given right over here.
Determine its x-intercept.
The x-intercept is the x
value when y is equal to 0,
or it's the x value
where our graph actually
intersects the x-axis.
Notice right over here
our y value is exactly 0.
We're sitting on the x-axis.
So let's think about what
this x value must be.
Well, just trying to
eyeball a little bit,
it's a little over 2.
It's between 2 and 3.
It looks like it's
less than 2 and 1/2.
But we don't know
the exact value.
So let's go turn to the equation
to figure out the exact value.
We essentially
have to figure out
what x value, when
y is equal to 0,
will have this equation be true.
So we could just say 2 times
0 plus 3x is equal to 7.
Well, 2 times 0 is
just going to be 0,
so we have 3x is equal to 7.
Then we can divide both
sides by 3 to solve for x,
and we get x is equal to 7/3.
Does that look like 7/3?
Well, we just have
to remind ourselves
that 7/3 is the same
thing as 6/3 plus 1/3.
And 6/3 is 2.
So this is the same
thing as 2 and 1/3.
Another way you could
think about it is 3
goes into 7 two times, and
then you have a remainder of 1.
So you've still got
to divide that 1 by 3.
It's 2 full times
and then a 1/3,
so this looks like 2 and 1/3.
And so that's its
x-intercept, 7/3.
If I was doing this on the
exercise on Khan Academy,
it's always a little easier to
type in the improper fraction,
so I would put in 7/3.